this is camp et for tiny people but we
have two big people me and Collins key
hello hey is my head even in the frame
right now I don't know my god this is
gonna be obvious like some bug on the
top of the chair right now a back of it
take a knee and then just work your way
in okay all right well you really
committed to sitting in it well welcome
thank you for having me
of course now did you ever go to camp as
a kid I did gymnastics camp okay
it wasn't like camp it was just
basically grueling hours of like trying
to do flips and impossible ways but yeah
I had a great time though how many
VidCon for you is this this might be my
sec second or third I'm not sure exactly
someone that ball someone that ball
barking I'm not sure it's bigger than
ever 30,000 people Wow
yeah I know it's huge I think it's it's
better managed though yeah like it's
like it's fun because I can actually
spend time with the fans now where
before they you couldn't go anywhere
without it just being craziness now you
get a little more like one-on-one time
with fans and like it's it's it handled
better in that sense so I really I
really enjoyed that cuz I loved
interacting one-on-one and just meeting
the people who like watch the videos and
like you support and so it was really
fun did you ever expect when you did
America's Got Talent that you would be
here it's crazy because like I remember
I came to my first VidCon was when I was
on America's Got Talent and at that
point I had like 50,000 subscribers I
like jet start my YouTube channel and
like this year to be coming back and
like just hit a million on YouTube and
like it's it's really crazy it's like
been putting in work so it's it's fun to
come back to VidCon every year and like
it sounds like a milestone you can see
where you're at
have you had any great or crazy or weird
fan experiences so far this year
yeah the craziest one I've had is I had
a fan and a meet-and-greet come up to me
give me a big hug which is like I love
hugs and everything but then she started
like chewing on Mikey and like she
started trying to swallow Mikey necklace
like gnawing on the cord so that was and
like she's like a death grip on me too
so that was probably the craziest one
that's happened cuz like this is a
family heirloom it's been in our family
for over a hundred years and it's like
it's really special to me like reminds
me family clothes and then some girl
tried to eat it
I hope you've sanitized Oh bro it was so
shiny after I was done it was so shiny
yeah all right so this is actually right
here this is how a magician makes money
cuz I've got a few bills here I think
like five but nothing nothing too crazy
on the count of three I'm gonna have you
snap all right here we go and watch the
bills walk we go one two three like that
oh that's um that's that's how a
magician makes money especially for
summertime it's like the way to go so
2016 what else can we expect from
Collins key I'm actually working with
AT&T right now for project they have
hello lab basically I get the
opportunity to create whatever I want
which is so much fun and I have a crazy
idea that I've had for years now and the
way hey we're gonna do it so that's
gonna be coming out on my YouTube
channel coming up here very shortly
details are all like my socials of one
is gonna be launched but super excited
about that so keep an eye on that that
sounds like a dream come true
yes thank you so much for coming to camp
et call yeah thank you for having me